The ability to perceive motion
is so important to us humans
that we can easily fool our eyes into
seeing movement that isn't actually there.
In this activity you and your kids
will create your very own animations.
Today we are going to
have a look at these interesting things here.
These are called thaumatropes.
Can you see there are some pictures on them
here?
Do you want to take a look?
Tell me what you can see
and what you think they might be for.
So it makes you... It looks like a movement,
so it's like that and then it explodes.
So we are going to have
a go at making these ourselves today.
And I've been to the Ri website
and downloaded and printed off these templates.
So we are going to use these.
And there's only one rule to this really
and that rule is
that you have to draw the
picture the same way up on here.
So when you fold them over
and you spin them around
they're both looking the same way up.
Draw one image in the top half of the
template and another image in the bottom half.
Ask your kids lots of questions about
what they think will work best and why.
Then carefully cut out the shape.
Glue some string or a thin skewer to the
middle of the template and fold the other
side over.
It works.
It does actually, doesn't it?
- Let me try.
This little toy is called a thaumatrope and
it
takes advantage of our persistence of vision.
This means that the image on one side of the
toy
lingers in our vision long enough
that we see it overlap with the image on the
other side.
The faster you spin it, the better the illusion
becomes.
OK, Daniel, when you look at this picture,
and you see a picture of two people,
are they moving?
No.
So it's just like a picture of
two people that are not moving.
Do you think it would be quite fun to try
and create something where it
looks like the picture inside is moving?
I know how!
So we've got this funny picture on a disk.
Shall we try... I think a really good way
to make this picture spin
is to pop this pencil in the middle of it
and then try to spin it around.
So do you want to?
It doesn't work.
- Doesn't work?
Ask your kids if they can figure out how
to get this phenakistiscope to work.
Why do you think we've got a mirror on the
table?
Do you think that has something to do with
this activity?
Yeah, obviously, because it's on the table.
Suggest they peer through the slots at the
mirror while you spin the disk.
It's working!
- So tell me what's happening?
He's walking really fast.
- He's walking?
And we've got some blank templates here
that we've printed off again from the Ri website.
So we can have one each. So we're going to
do the drawings first and then you can cut
them out afterwards.
So you've got to try and think of something
in it that's going to do some kind of gentle movement.
It's working!
Now you do it,
now you do it! - OK.
When you watch any kind of moving image on
a screen, including this video, what you're
really seeing is a series of still images,
like these, where the subject in the images
changes position slightly each time. If the
images are shown quickly enough we perceive
movement.
Why don't we work out why we think this is
actually looking like something that's moving
when we look through.
So is it like in a cartoon? It's just lots
of pictures animated together so it's like
that. But when it's mirrored and kind of like,
you know like, you can't really see it, it
tricks your mind to assume that it's moving,
because you can't quite see. - OK.
These phenakistiscopes also have a series
if images on them. When viewed in the mirror,
through the passing slits, we're only able
to see the images one at a time in quick succession,
so we perceive movement.
We've had lots of fun today doing this activity.
If you want to have a go at it yourself you
can go to the Ri website and download the
templates. Don't forget to like and subscribe.